[Laughter]
[Music]
today we are going to be giving our
friends a couple of pictures Halloween
treats so they're gonna be three options
spooky spooky er and spooky yes which is
my face I really don't know one punches
me in the face our first pair is coming
I'm gonna crawl under the table I'm
gonna remain there the rest of the day
I'm gonna pull my back doing this I know
it already we're trying Instagram evil
Halloween treats I like to trick people
sometimes I like to be tricky and sly I
love Halloween
what are gonna be this here it's the
only day where I get to dress up as
someone else shuttle buddy a
trick-or-treat I just got candy why did
a two three look just a bug give it a
crunch I'm going to pull apart my spider
I'll kill him
it's good I like the salty on the street
together yeah so now we're gonna do this
poopy or Treat presentation ah okay I
feel the spooks in my soul I like the
candy with the chocolate I was in recess
isn't it it's an apple no I thought it
was like a cake I love apples
this is a lot better than that session
and now we're gonna try a spookiest
oh my god I just broke the whole table
got a tsunami spirit yeah you got us
oh absolutely terrifying you ride away
I'm just gonna say you're lucky that I
didn't smack you for the head with that
pan I was that was my second reaction
look at me I'm shaking I'm really
shaking we knew we realized there was
something there
[Laughter]
[Music]